there's a new policy from British
cycling determining how transgender
women can compete
female events will only be for Riders
assigned female at Birth and transgender
men who are yet to begin hormone therapy
there will be a new open category for
those assign male at Birth transgender
men transgender women and individuals
who identify as non-binary
the science isn't certain so why go
against inclusivity
we've looked at a range of different
masses in getting to this point first of
all is to consult with our athletes
secondly is to look at the scientific
research that is available at this point
in time and thirdly is from a legal
perspective
previously transgender women had to have
testosterone levels below a certain
point to compete in female events but
British cycling suspended that policy
after facing a threat of boycotts by
female Riders over the potential
participation in events by the
transgender cyclist Emily Bridges she
came out as a transgender woman in 2020
and continued to compete in events as a
male while undergoing a transition she
won a points race at a university event
but the world governing body said she
was ineligible for her first female
event because she was still registered
as a male
the review of the policy by British
cycling has been taking place since then
British cycling have apologized for the
anxiety cause during the delay forming
the new policy but Emily Bridges is
outraged calling the decision a violent
act and questioning whether she wants to
even race anymore
the British cycling decision reflects
those from Triathlon and Athletics in
creating a new open category British
cycling say transgender women can still
compete in female events in
non-competitive categories foreign